a thousand years ago in 1977 when I was
an intern at the Great Lake Shakespeare
Festival my first professional job we
all got yelled at by Dan Sullivan the
director he said hey look you you guys
you guys you actors you know what your
job is you know what your job is you
have got to show up on time and you have
to know the text and you have to have a
head full of ideas otherwise I can't do
my job that was the greatest lesson a
young actor could possibly ever get
first of all a head full of ideas bring
anything try anything they might not use
it if it stinks they won't use it
knowing the text and it's not just your
lines it's the whole thing it's the Red
Dot it's the theme of the movie you've
got to know it you might not be right in
what the opinion that you bring to it
but you've got to come at it with some
direction showing up on time is one of
the greatest liberating acts you can
give yourself in a movie